glenn greenwald
pulitzer prize winning journalist joins
me now do you feel it glenn
oh for sure you can feel the power
shifting from these older power centers
like news networks and even some of
these mass media outlets who used to
have the capacity when they united
to instantly destroy somebody to demand
their d platforming and have it done
overnight and now as you said when they
attack
they're essentially making their target
stronger because they fail each time
that something like this happens where
they want joe rogan removed and spotify
says no or they attack sub-stack and
they issue a defiant statement saying
we're not going to censor it deflates
the potency of these tactics and it
shows the public that the media no
longer has this power and it makes their
target seem like
martyred dissidents and people want to
pay more attention it's like the bully
that he hits you in the face and you
don't fall down and everybody else
that's been bullied said wait a second
this guy can't throw a punch like he
used to like you said he doesn't have
the potency and then they're also
falling because of these woke rules that
they themselves used you know they're
getting me too they're getting canceled
they're canceling themselves it's
silliness now there's no sense of
forgiveness
do you think that they can recover i
don't see them ever coming back
no i think first of all they way over
play their hand people see that they're
on this kind of orgy like this obsession
to censor not just the occasional voice
any longer like in alex jones here or
milo yiannopoulos there but every day
there's a new person that needs to be
silenced and i think the american public
instinctively finds that repellent and
then i think you're also right that the
rules that they've created they wanted
to impose on others are now ensnaring
themselves and people see
that if you're a worker and you say the
wrong thing you get destroyed but if
you're whoopi goldberg and say something
kind of stunning even though it was at
my view without malice and just out of
ignorance they rush to her aid and
defend her and these kind of double
standards are also something people find
repulsive and i think the more they do
it the more they're being unmasked i
couldn't agree more they are being
unmasked glenn greenwald thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else